in 2010 then Home Secretary Theresa May
introduced a series of policies aimed at
creating a hostile environment for
illegal immigrants by April 2018 the
hostile chickens came home to roost when
it was revealed this policy had
negatively impacted legal British
citizens from the Windrush generation
rightly the British public was outraged
but what hasn't been adequately
addressed is a knock-on impact that this
hostile environment has had on
immigrants in general along with the
negative narrative around immigration
during the EU referendum campaign this
provided the perfect storm for a
significant rise in hate crimes post the
brexit vote so it's no surprise this
fear of the other is now impacting our
children last week there was public
outrage when a video went viral
featuring an alleged bullying incident
of a Syrian refugee in a school in
Huddersfield I fear that if a hostile
environment remains unchecked incidents
like this will become the norm the
government needs to act now to preempt
any anti-immigrant backlash by
introducing integration lessons into our
curriculum and similar programs for
adults this could go a long way in
helping us become a truly United Kingdom
[Music]
before we think about integration
lessons which is a for me yet another
thing to put on the curriculum I would
just would like to tell the panel I went
to Syria about 10 years ago and frankly
I thought it was a far more civilised
country than many I visited in Europe I
you know I went round the Crusader
castles I went to Homs I went to the
Suk's in Aleppo and Damascus you know it
was the most welcoming warm civilised
country and now it has been completely
brutalized 11 million people have left
Syria and we have only taken 10 thousand
which I think is about a thousand a
thousand that I can't even say if that I
mean it's a tiny tiny amount and the
fact that when they find refuge in this
country they are met with racist abuse
and bullying is
absolutely shocking and is a national
disgrace your thing I have I yeah you're
right I don't have a Syrian in my Space
Jam you're quite right fistrick yeah I
don't I mean I think the point is is
that June's June's right to say that
this country has become a hostile
environment and not just for Cypriot
Syrian refugees and June is right in
saying we must all check ourselves and
when you see somebody or hear somebody
speaking foreign language you don't say
we voted we voted leave you know you
should go back to your country there are
missing that this is what the Home
Office has said in this before you come
in cow cause I know you're gonna come in
can we have a look actually I'm going to
bring in a grab first by Iman Atta who's
the director of tell mama project which
records and measures anti-muslim
incidents in the UK brexit has actually
shed the light on anyone who's different
anyone who spoke differently anyone who
was uttered and this dynamic state for a
long time it did not just go after
breakfast it did not diminish cuz you've
got as well there few G crises are
taking place in Europe the impact of
that and the narrative of some of the
campaign's that actually led to brexit
that actually have driven that racial
and anti-muslim aggravation okay here
the bullying in any way shape or form is
wrong but what really upset me about
this particular one was what what how it
was taken on social media bullying is
happening at all of our schools every
day not just to immigrant kids every kid
who was picked on is picked on because
they're perceived to be different
whether they're overweight they wear
glasses they're a bit shy whatever it is
so but I watched what social media did
with us in the day and it was disgusting
the lefty was did to try and say that
that Britain post brexit focused on
looking about holding a per se because
what happened this was made a political
football and indeed navee this is
bullying is not just about for
immigrants getting bullied it's about
everyone counts so then what's your
answer to the increase in hate crimes if
we look at the statistics
you do that I'm ready you ready for it
would these include the hate crimes such
as the Spanish restaurant that was
allegedly clicked because they were
special and in fact it was a burglary
but they include the hate crime will
involve servants cable who said of
brexit voters they want to go back to a
time when faces were white and passports
were blue and that was an alleged hate
crime would it also include the problem
lady Somerset in Somerset so if we bring
up our stats here so we had ninety four
thousand and ninety eight hate crimes
recorded by the police in England and
Wales in 2017 to 2018
that's an increase by 17 percent do you
think it was right that this crime as
used to hold a crime it was you had an
inner bully
the the other boy who was now we're told
has fled the country I am not in any way
saying we should demonize the boy I am
saying that actually if you look at what
happened they are a victim of what's
going on they're alive victims and this
was made into a victim this has made it
to initial baby immigration its
anti-immigrant narrative if we don't
look at this hostile environment what we
saw in that video it'll be something
like thousands of kids who want emigrate
I am I've got a friend who's a Indian
background 30s brought up here went to
school here interesting he said up to
the brick gym but he never encountered I
have any sort of emotional abuse and in
that week afterwards now whether he's
still getting I don't know I think it
could be more positive I mean let's look
at there's a clip from the guy whose
deputy leader of Bradford Council
talking about when they took mixed race
good you know basically Asian and white
away together okay we took him away on a
residential to give them an opportunity
to do some group activities together a
bit of a team-building type exercise and
it was really interesting that on the
first day that you could see that there
was a almost a barrier between the two
groups but by day three they actually
really come together and gelled quite
well because they were young children
that wanted to be children and and there
are some positive bits there are some
positive I mean if you looked
the reaction to the guy this week the
Tottenham bananas get no he says he
didn't even think about it being a
banana which you might be right but
anyway he felt banana skin oh yeah there
was a black fire it wasn't twenty years
ago but this is my point Greg my point
is as a country let me finish please so
my point is as a country we have come so
far on this issue we have so much to
teach the world on this issue and if we
don't check what's brewing all of the
work that we've done in the past thirty
years could unravel dude that's what I'm
talking about don't you see it's not too
much doom and gloom
well I'm what I'm saying is we've got to
look at what's going we've also got a
look at the data in terms of the amount
of people they are experiencing my real
haze chronic what you talked about
integration what would be your if you
were let's say a team I don't know how
we've had multiculturalism and now you
aren't saying what we need is
integration yeah twofold I think if you
look at the Windrush generation when
they were first coming over here and
even when you look at the expelled Asian
community the idiom mean expelled in the
70s before those communities arrived
there was preparation you saw all of the
news bulletins you saw what was going on
in their countries we prepared that we
prepared Britain for this new influx of
immigrants and I think that actually
what schools need to do particularly in
areas where you have a large influx of
immigrants schools need to have classes
where we teach children about where
those kids have come from because back
to that incident I genuinely believe if
that kid had known what that Syrian
refugees family had been through it was
no way he would have been bullying here
totally u-turn actually we then look at
what our shared narrative is what is it
the word want you to create together as
a country are you not looking back at
the Windrush generation with this sort
of a certain I don't think your why
don't you I think I am
[Laughter]
at that time Brixton which today is an
incredibly fashionable multicam mixin
was like that in the night I agree of
course there were problems we know there
were problems but my goodness I think
there would have been far worse problems
had that preparation are you writing it
no but I know I'm right that I've got to
get this in out of the words of
Education Minister Madame's oh how are
we harassment or bullying of any kind is
completely unacceptable and abhorrent in
any setting including schools both the
police and the local authority are
investigating this incident the
department will support them in any way
we can schools have a role in promoting
community cohesion and integration and
are required to support pupils spiritual
moral social and cultural development
and promote fundamental British values
this is a priority for the deep you're
right thank you